EVENING AND WELCOME TO THE
MONDAY AUGUST THE THIRTY FIRST
MEETING OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOMEBODY AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CREDIT. AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILL
HERE. TO HEAR DEEP DEEP HERE
GABRIEL APRIL HERE GLORIA
GLORIA HERE KILEY IMAN
MAIENSCHEIN QUICK SILVA. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A CORE. DUE TO
CONTINUE TO STAY AT HOME ORDERS
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SURE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE
A LIMITED NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WATCHING PARTICIPATE IN THIS
HEARING IN PERSON. WE ALSO
REQUIRE THAT MASS BE WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFIED WHETHER
HERE IN THIS ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE AMASSED WE WILL
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE
SEVERAL OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONIES TODAY. FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THIS ROOM IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WISHES TO
TESTIFY PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
ALASSIA APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. ASK
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFIED. OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. FOR RTS WITNESSES
IF THERE ARE ANY IN ADDITION TO
TESTIFYING FROM THIS ROOM WE
HAVE SOME BILL WITNESSES MAKING
USE OF REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS AND A FEW OTHER
LOCATIONS AROUND THE STATE.
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THE TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE
THE HEARING ROOM AND ASK THEM
QUESTIONS. WE ALSO WILL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANYONE IS
MAY TESTIFIED. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING. IS.
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO. ZERO TWO TWO AGAIN THE
CALL IN NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO. ZERO
TWO TWO YOU'LL FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. YOU FOR
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON. HIS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATE ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU AND ON HOW
TO BE PLACE IN THE QUEUE. BASED
ON WHAT YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU WERE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
IF YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMSWITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2085 MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP. ALSO NOTE THAT
WE WILL BE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE MAY
NEED TO LIMIT HOW LONG THE
PHONE LINES ARE OPEN FOR EACH
BILL BECAUSE WE ARE IN A VERY
TIGHT. SCHEDULE IN FACT I THINK
THERE ARE THREE HEARINGS THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN BACK TO BACK IN
THE NEXT HOUR OR SO THANK YOU
FOR PATIENTS WITH LIMITED BEEN
WITNESSES TO EACH SIDE EACH
PERSON HAS TWO MINUTES TO SPEAK.
AND WITH THAT LET US COOPER.
ITEM HELLO ONE. AB SIXTY NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG. OKAY
MISTER GRAYSON IS TO GO FIRST
SO WE'RE GOING TO FILE AND
THREE AB EIGHT THIRTY ONE
MISTER GRAYSON THANK YOU MISTER
TECH FOR ALLOWING HIM TO GO
FIRST. AND THE DICES YOURS.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM SERVICES
CONSTRUCTING FOR ALLOWING ME TO
STEP THEN I'VE GOT ANOTHER BILL
TO PRESENT ANOTHER COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB EIGHT THIRTY ONE
WHICH WILL ALLOW QUALIFIED
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS TO
BE EFFECTIVELY USE OR TO
EFFECTIVELY USE THE STREAMLINED
APPROVAL PROCESS. ESTABLISHED
BY SB THIRTY FIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS ONLY
EXASPERATED CALIFORNIA'S
ONGOING HOUSING CRISIS AS
SOARING UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS
LEAVE MANY UN. UNABLE TO AFFORD
HOUSING AND ON THE BRINK OF
EVICTION. SB THIRTY FIVE WAS A
LANDMARK EFFORT TO INCREASE OUR
HOUSING SUPPLY. IT'S
STREAMLINED THE APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR QUALIFYING HOUSING
PROJECTS IN LOCALITIES THAT
FAILED TO MEET THEIR REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS. ASSESSMENT GOALS
HOWEVER SINCE ITS
IMPLEMENTATION AMBIGUITIES IN
SB THIRTY FIVES LANGUAGE HAVE
BEEN EXPLOITED TO DE RAIL
DESPERATELY NEEDED HOUSING
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE. AB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE MAKES THREE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. ABOUT TO
ADDRESS THESE EMERGING ISSUES
FIRST IT ALLOWS FOR MODEST
MODIFICATIONS TO AN SB THIRTY
FIVE PROJECT WITHOUT REQUIRING
THE DEVELOPER TO APPLY FOR A
NEW PROJECT APPROVAL. SECOND IT
REFINES THE PERMITTING PROCESS
FOR CONNECTING AND SB THIRTY
FIVE PROJECT TO EXISTING PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE LASTLY AB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE CLARIFIES THAT THE
TWO THIRD RESIDENTIAL
REQUIREMENT IN SB THIRTY FIVE
APPLIES TO. OBJECT ITSELF NOT
THE ZONING FOR THE SITE THAT
THE PROJECT IS BUILT ON WITH
THESE CHANGES AB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE WILL ENSURE THAT QUALIFYING
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
CAN BE EFFECTIVELY STREAMLINED
AS INTENDED UNDER SB THIRTY
FIVE. I DO HAVE A WITNESS-
MISTER CHAIRMAN- MY WITNESSES
MICHAEL LANE WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING AND
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION.
THANK THANK YOU THIS TIME I
LIKE TO ASK THE OPERATOR TO
PLEASE ALLOW THE FIRST AND ONE
WITNESS MISTER MICHAEL LANE TO
TESTIFY BY TELEPHONE. YOU'RE
CUTE NUMBERS HI MICHAEL IN HERE
WAS BURKE. SB THIRTY FIVE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALLOWS BECAUSE
THEY WANTED HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS TO COMPLY WITH
LOCAL ZONING. AND IT IS BETTER
TO THE JURISDICTIONS NOT
PARTICIPATION HOUSING A VERY
SAD TIME LEVELS CALLED FOR ITS
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION. OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS LAW WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION. ON
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO ENSURE
THAT APPLICATION OF THE LAW
ALIGNS WITH THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE. THIS BILL INCLUDES
THREE POINTS OF CLARIFICATION.
ONE MINOR DESIGN MODIFICATIONS
ARE ALLOWED AS LONG AS
OBJECTIVE. STANDARDS CONTINUE
TO BE MET. TO THE NECESSARY
OFFLINE IMPROVEMENTS REQUIRED
TO EMPLOY AND THAT'S THIRTY
FIVE FOUR. BUT BE APPROVED. AND
THREE TO TWO THIRDS RESIDENTIAL
REQUIREMENT APPLIES TO THE
PROPOSED PROJECT. AND NOT THE
SITE RESOUNDING. MIXED USE ON
COMMERCIAL ZONES THAT ALLOW
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS COULD
NOT TYPICALLY REQUIRE. A TWO
THIRDS OF THE SITE BE DEDICATED
TO A RESIDENTIAL USE. THESE
TARGET CLARIFICATIONS PROVIDE
GREATER CERTAINTY UNDERSTANDING
OF THE STATUTE FOR BOTH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND DEVELOPERS.
AND ENSURE THE PROMISE THAT
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF SB THIRTY
FIVE. CAN PEOPLE FILLED WITH
RESPECTIVE REQUEST AND I BOTH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS TIME
LET'S OPEN THE LINE UP TO ANY.
INDIVIDUALS FROM THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IF YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL YOU
CAN STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND SIMPLY THE
FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT SO FOR
EXAMPLE MICHAEL LANE. SPUR I
SUPPORT THE BILL. TO THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
OPEN UP ONCE. IF YOU IF YOU ARE
A PART OF THIS BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. AND WE WILL
GO TO THE LINE OF FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
KELLY GAP WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND NEXT FINAL GO TO LINE SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOLLY FOR
MEETING ON BEHALF OF A THREE
PEAT COALITION WORKING GROUP CO
CHAIR I THINK IT HALL AT THE
FOUNDATION AND TMG PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF FIVE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX
TOWARDS WITH STRATEGIES PREFIX
YEAH BEHALF OF UP FOR GROWTH
ACTION CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING THIS IS ERIN
EVAN BOND BEHALF OF THE SAMPLE
PROPERTY COMPANY AND HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
SIXTY THREE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING THIS
IS A PHILADELPHIA CRANE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAKE AN
APPEARANCE SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND THERE IS
NO NOTHING YOU IN SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU LET'S
NOT GO TO OPPOSITION IF THERE
ARE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THE WISH TO OPPOSE THERE'S NO
WHICH- MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESS
LET'S GO TO. THE PHONE LINES.
GIVE YOU AN APPLICATION OF THE
BILL YOU MAY PRESS. ONE ZERO.
ONE MOMENT YOU'RE CARE. THE
BOTTOM LINE OF SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NINE SIXTY FOUR.
HI THIS IS KELLY BALLOT IN THE
VERY HELPFUL IN SUPPORT. YOU
KNOW IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND THERE IS NO ONE INK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITHOUT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS MISS QUICK SILVA. I
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION I JUST
HAVE ON COMPLEMENT WHICH IS.
THAT I THINK THIS IS- EXCELLENT
BILL AND IT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE
NEED WE HAVE BEEN TALKING- FOUR
I'M GONNA SAY MANY YEARS NOW
BUT AT LEAST IF THE RECENT LAST
FEW YEARS ABOUT OUR PRODUCTION
AND HOUSING AND HOW MANY MANY
TIMES. WE GET A PROJECT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THEY ACTUALLY GET
THE NIGHT AND HAVE TO START ALL
OVER BECAUSE OF. SOME OF THE
THINGS WHETHER IT'S A MINOR
CHANGE. OR OR EVEN. THE PUBLIC
NOT WANTING THE PROJECT BUT
ALSO THIS. FOCUSES ON MARINA.
AND WE'VE SEEN ALL TOO OFTEN.
CITIES NOT NOT TO COMPLY WITH
THIS AND- SO IS THIS WILL MKE
IT CLEAR. IT WILL ALSO MAKE AT
OUR HOUSING- MOVE FASTER
HOPEFULLY AND WE NEED TO GET
BUILDING. THANK TO THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CASTANETS A
MOTION TO MOVE THE MOTION TO
MOVE TOWARDS OUR SECOND. OKAY
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION. ANY
FINAL COMMENTS MR GRAYSON.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING SAID
THIS BILL- I AM HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT IT'S A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO ENSURING THAT SB
THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS GET MINOR
REASONABLE MODIFICATIONS AND
PROVIDE MORE CLARITY FOR ALL
PARTIES IN THIS PROCESS AND
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO RECOMMEND THAT THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO BE
CONCURRED IN CHICO HI CHIU I'D
DEEP. DEEP AYE GABRIEL. GABRIEL
I GLORIA. GLORIA AYE AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE ON. MAIENSCHEIN QUICK
SERVICE HI YOUR BILL YOUR BILLS
OUT. WAY FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON LET'S CALL ONE AB SIXTY
NINE MISTER TANK. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE- YOU HOSTED MANY. AB
SIXTY NINE HELPS FILL THE GAP
BY PROVIDING HOMEOWNERS WITH
BRIDGE LOANS TO FINANCE EIGHTY
YOU CONSTRUCTION UNTIL THEY CAN
QUALIFY FOR EXISTING LOAN
PROGRAMS THE BILL CREATES A
FRAMEWORK AND PASSED THE
TREASURER IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
EACH CD AND CAL HFA. DESIGNING
A REVENUE NEUTRAL PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP LOAN
PROGRAM TO HELP SPUR EDIE YOU
DEVELOPMENT- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES-
SUPPORT OF ALL THE DIFFERENT
PIECES OF EIGHTY LEGISLATION
THAT I'VE GONE THROUGH THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS. WE THINK THIS
IS A GREAT SOLUTION FOR MANY
MIDDLE CLASS HOMEOWNERS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO TAKING YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU LETTERS NOW
GO TO YOUR FIRST WITNESS- TO
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE LUBBOCK JOHNSON FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE. LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST FOR OUR STATE TREASURE
TO TESTIFY. GOOD EVENING
CHAIRED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I AM THE BLACK
JOHNSON NONETHELESS A VALIDATOR
KIANA MAILLET. IT SHOULD BE THE
PROPER CODE BONTA OF AB SIXTY
NINE BY SOME MEMBER TEAM. WHICH
IS CREATING EFFECTIVE TOOL TO
UNTANGLE THE RED TAPE AROUND
THE. FINANCING BECAUSE WE DO
ALL THE- IN A ROLE THE
TREASURES IN RESPONSE FOR SO
IMPORT PROGRAM. THAT'S THE
POINT I THINK HOW DO YOU GO.
ALLOCATED CREDITS AND A PRICE
ACTIVITY BONTA. ARE NEED FOR
THE GRANT THE PLUG FOR THE
HOUSE AT ALL THE- HAVE NEVER
BEEN GREAT. AB SIXTEEN FOCUS IS
ON LET VISIBLE BUT STILL.
ELEMENT OF OUR STATE OVERALL
STRATEGY OF MAKING HOUSING MORE
PORTABLE ACROSS A WIDE SWATH OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH MINIMUM
INVESTMENT OF STATE FUNDS TO DO
SO. LOCAL ORDINANCES PERMITTING
THE CONSTRUCTION OF A FIFTY
BILLION IN OUR STATE HAVE
ACCELERATED IN RECENT YEARS.
BUT THE MEANS TO FINANCE UNIT
IT'S LACKING UNFORTUNATELY. IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE EXPAND
OUR FOR THE HOUSING OPTIONS. IN
THE BILL DOES JUST THAT. WITH
THAT DATE I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU SO MEMBER TANK WARS
LEADERSHIP. AND ARE STRICTLY
ALCORN I'VE BUILT TO SUPPORT
EXPEDITING THE PRACTICE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS TO
CALIFORNIA. WITH MEAT CAN
CHECK- ARE DEFEATED PUBLIC
FINANCE. WHO CAN ANSWER ANY
CANCEL QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANALYSTS
ARE NAY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
WHEN WE GO NOW TO OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. THEY WISH TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL O THE.
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES. THANK YOU
YOU ARE. OF THE BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. ZERO AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SIXTY LINE IS OPEN.
HOLLY FOR MEETING UP TO HAVE A
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND THAT AFTER THE KOBE AREA
RESEARCH INSTITUTE ALSO KNOWN
AS PER AND CLIPART. THANK YOU
AND ONE MOMENT IN FUTURE WE
HAVE TO GET ANOTHER LINE NUMBER
ONE MOMENT. AND THAT LINE
NUMBER WE WILL GO TO A FIFTY
EIGHT. FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING THIS IS-
CHRIS FOR CARLISLE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK AT THREE OF
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT WE HAVE
ANOTHER LINE COMING IN. THANK
YOU A LOCAL LINE OF SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THE
PHILADELPHIA ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FOR THE
LINE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME LET'S
HEAR FROM ANIMAL OF PUBLIC THE
WERE TO OPPOSE A BILL THERE IS
NO FORM OPPOSITION PRESS. IF
YOU COULD OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION. Q. IF YOU END UP
THE FIRST OF THE BILL MY PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. AND ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. AND
THERE IS NO ONE CARES OKAY
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I WANTTO
STACK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR HIS ONGOING WORK
ON EIGHTY USE FIRST TO REMOVE
PROCEDURAL HURDLES AND NOW
TEMPTING TO REMOVE FINANCIAL
HURDLES AND YOU'LL HAVE MY
SUPPORT. ANY OTHER COMMENTS. IS
OUR MOTION WITH THIS BILL. AS A
MOTION AND A SECOND ANY FINAL
COMMENTS MR TIME. JUST JUST
BEFORE I STRAP OF MADAM
SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS TO
RECOMMEND THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO BE CONCURRED IN
CHU Q. I DEEP. GABRIEL GABRIEL
I GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY KILEY
NO MON MAIENSCHEIN QUICK SILVA.
QUICKSILVER HI. THANK YOU MR
TANGUAY FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON. MR DAILY FILE AND TO AB
FOUR THIRTY THREE AT FOUR
THIRTY FOUR. THIS GO FOR YES
SENATE PLEASE. A LOT OF PEOPLE.
SIX THEY DID OF CHANGE THE
EFFECTIVE DATE- TWELVE TWELVE
MONTHS DOWN THE ROAD. BUT
OTHERWISE I'VE BY WE WOULD
RESPOND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT ON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET ME SEE I KNOW YOU HAVE
A WITNESS MARC STIVERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
ONLINE- IF THE OPERATOR COULD
PLEASE ALLOW MR STIVERS TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON IN PERSON HEY
MARK. PLEASE DIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP-
BEFORE OF THE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS ARE EXTREMELY
THANKFUL FOR ALL THE RESOURCES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LAST COUPLE
YEARS. FRACTURED NATURE OF THE
FUNDING IS ADDING SNEAK THAT
TIME COST RISK AND PLAN. TO THE
ALREADY DIFFICULT PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OUR GOAL IS TO CREATE A ONE
STOP SHOP FOR EACH CITY
RESOURCES AND AB THIRTY FORGETS
IS ALMOST ALL THE WAY THERE WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
AND WE ASK FOR RIVAL. GREAT LET
ME ASK OUR THE OPERATOR IF
THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. Q. AND IF
YOU AREN'T PART OF THE BILL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE UP FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TAKING A BAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING IN THE
COURT THANK YOU. YOU CAN. WE
WILL GO TO THE NEXT LINE OF
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING MARINO WHITE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MEGHAN EFFORT THE POOR YOU
MAY PRESS. ONE ZERO. THERE ARE
NO OTHER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THEY'RE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL. GIVE HER A
LINE OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. THEY
OPEN OPPOSITION. AND THERE IS
NO ETHNIC YOU MISTER CHAIR
GREAT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION YOUR
MOTION WITH THIS BILL FOR THE
MOTION AND A SECOND ONE OF THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK IN TRYING
TO STREAMLINE THE MANY FUNNY
PROGRAMS HCD APPRECIATE YOUR
PERSEVERANCE ON THIS AND HAPPY
TO SUPPORT. ANY FINAL COMMENTS
JUST I WILL APPRECIATE. SUPPORT
BOAT THANK YOU GREAT. MADAM
SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS TO
RECOMMEND THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO BE CONCURRED AND
SHE'LL. SHE'LL I DEEP. GABRIEL
GABRIEL I GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE LIMóN. MANGE
QUICK SILVA. QUICK SILVA I WILL
WAIT FOR A MEMBER THANK YOU
MISTER DALY THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH SEE ON THE FLOOR SHE ON
THE FLOOR BY. FOURTH ITEM FILE
ON FOUR EIGHTY FIFTEEN SIXTY
ONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA. OKAY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE. OF SENATE AMENDMENTS
THAT ALLOW IT TO BE FIFTEEN ONE
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE MAKING IT
CRITICAL RESPONSE TO COVER
NINETEEN CHRIS IS MR SIX EXTEND
HEALTH ENTITLEMENTS AND PERMITS
NECESSARY TO THE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING TO HELP TWENTY AFTER
INSURING THE CRITICAL PIPELINE
OF PROJECTS REMAIN ALIVE.
SECOND THIS BILL ENCOURAGES A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HEALTH
ELEMENTS INCLUDE AN ANALYSIS OF
GOVERNMENTAL CONSTRAINTS UPON
HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS%
IDENTIFIED UNDER THE UNDER THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT. OR PROTECT
THE CLASS OF OUR POPULATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU LET'S GO FOR ME
WOULD. ON THE PHONE LINES OF
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ALLOW MISTER MICHAEL
GUNNING FROM THE CIA TO TESTIFY.
MEMBERS MICHAEL GETTING HIT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IS A PROUD
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE TODAY. WE
WANT TO THANK OUR CO THE FAMILY
MEMBERS GREAT BASIN IMMACULATE
CURRY BUT PARTICULAR THANKS TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS MEASURE.
MISTER CALDERON THANK YOU AND
ALL THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THAT CREDIBLE
ENGAGEMENT ALMOST MEASURE OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS. IN THE
DOWNTIMES OF THE NINETIES AND
AGAIN IN THE RECESSION OF THE
TWO THOUSAND THE LEGISLATURE
ACTED SWIFTLY TO EXTEND THE
LIFE OF CERTAIN ALREADY
IMPROVED ENTITLEMENTS
PROTECTING THE HOUSING SUPPLY
PIPELINE IS THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT ACTION TO ENSURE THAT
THE HOUSING PROJECTS OF ALL
KIND. ARE READY WHEN THE
ECONOMY AND MARKET RETURNS THE
LEGISLATURE IS MADE A VERY
CLEAR STATEMENT DURING PAST
RECESSIONS THAT PROTECTING
THESE PROJECTS TO THE STATEWIDE
IMPORTANCE. AND GIVEN THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC IT'S NEVER
BEEN MORE IMPORTANT THAN NOW.
IMPORTANT MEASURE ENSURES THAT
THE ALREADY LIMITED HOUSING
PIPELINE DOES NOT DRY UP DUE TO
THIS PANDEMIC WILL ALSO LOOK TO
THE FUTURE TO PROVIDE GREATER
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
AND PARTICULARLY IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE
REPRESENTS A BETTER FUTURE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND A PIPELINE TO TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS THAT WILL BE
REALIZE BECAUSE OF THE
PROTECTION OF THE PROJECT WITH
THAT I THANK YOU. AND WE CAN
LIVE UP THANK YOU MISTER
RUNNING LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC I
WISH TO STATE THEIR SUPPORT.
FOR THIS BILL. TO THE OPERATOR.
YOUR YOU WANT OF IT WELL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TELL OF SIX YOUR LINE OF THE-
GOOD EVENING HERE ATOMIZER THE
CALIFORNIACHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HOLLY FOR MANY ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND
THE DIFFERENT THE KOBE AREA
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWN AS BURKE
AND PARKS. THANK YOU AGAIN IF
YOU WERE IN UPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE'S NO ONE IN CUBA
STRUCTURE THANK YOU LET ME ASK
IF THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC THE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THERE IS NO MAIN
OPPOSITION- THIS CALL TO SEE IF
THEY'RE ANY. MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO STATE THEIR
OPPOSITION. TO THE OPERATOR. IF
YOU'RE NOT THE VISION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THERE
IS NO ONE IN Q. MESSENGER HER
RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND COMMENTS. THERE'S
A MOTION OF IT FORD IS OUR
SECOND. AS A MOTION AND A
SECOND JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL TO ENSURE
WE GET MORE HOUSING BUILT AS WE
RESPOND TO THE CALL THE
PANDEMIC. IS THERE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS- IS GARCIA.
RESPECTFULLY ASK A NAY VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS
TO RECOMMEND THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO BE CONCURRED IN.
SHE'LL HI Q. ID. GABRIEL
GABRIEL I GLORIA GLORIA I'D-
KILEY EILEEN. MAIENSCHEIN COOKS
UP. QUICK SERVE BY. WE WILL
LEAVE THAT ITEM OPEN FOR
FURTHER ON ST LOUIS SAY BEFORE
FOR ITEM THIS IS OUR LAST TO
HOUSING COMMITTEE MEETING OF
THIS YEAR- BUT IN PARTICULAR I
WANT TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
COLLEAGUE MISTER GLORIA WHO'S
BEEN JUST A TREMENDOUS CHAMPION
FOR HOUSING AND- WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO BIGGER AND BETTER
THINGS FROM HIM AS HE SOLVE THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN SAN DIEGO. SO
WITH THAT I'M GONNA HANDICAP
OVER TO HIM- FOR FILE ITEM FIVE
AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH IS
MINE.
ALEX TOMORROW THE
CALIFORNIA JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S
EMERGENCY RULE ONE WILL BE
RESCINDED IN TENANTS ACROSS THE
STATE WILL BE LEFT WITHOUT
PROTECTIONS FOR ADDICTIONS. I
WILL BE THE FIRST TO SAY THAT
THIS BILL IS FAR FROM PERFECT.
MANY OF THE TEN A PROTECTIONS
THAT I'VE FOUGHT FOR IN THE
ORIGINAL VERSION OF THIS BILL
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX ARE NOT
IN THIS BILL. BUT WE MUST PUT
IN TEMPORARY PROTECTIONS TO GET
US THROUGH THE NEXT FIVE
MONTHS. WITHOUT A WAVE OF
EVICTIONS. MILLIONS HAVE LOST
THEIR JOBS IN OUR STATE THROUGH
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN. WE CAN'T
ALLOW OBJECTIONS TO RESUME. FOR
STILL VERY MUCH IN THE MIDDLE.
OF A PUBLIC HEALTH. PANDEMIC
THIS BILL WILL NOT PREVENT
EVERY FICTIONAL FOR CLOSURE.
BUT IT WILL PREVENT MANY OF
ACTIONS AND DELAY MANY OTHERS
IT'S CRITICAL FOR RENTERS. FOR
HOUSING MARKET. FOR ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND FOR CONTAINING
KOBE NINETEEN. NINETY JUST TAKE
A MOMENT TO THANK THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS WHO CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS BILL. INCLUDING HUNDREDS
OF ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
TENANTS. PROGRESSIVE EQUITY AND
LABOR INTERESTS. I WANT TO
THANK FROM THE INDUSTRY TO
CALIFORNIA PARDON ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA. OF REALTORS THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION THE BANKING
COMMUNITY. AND MANY COLLEAGUES
FROM BOTH HOUSES OF THIS
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL. AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT WILL DO A
NUMBER OF THINGS FIRST FOR
TENANTS. THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT NO OBJECTIONS FOR MISS
RENT CAN GO FOR AGAINST TENANTS
WITH COVERT HARDSHIPS FOR THE
NEXT FIVE MONTHS. UNTIL
FEBRUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. TENANTS WILL BE REQUIRED
TO DECLARE UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
THE PREVENTS THEM FROM PAYING
RENT ON TIME. ONCE ATTENDED
ESTABLISHES AND ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP THEY CAN'T BE EVICTED
FOR RENT PAYMENTS OR MISTER IN
THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS OF THE
COVERED PANDEMIC. IT WILL STILL
OWE THE FULL AMOUNT TO THEIR
LANDLORD AND THEY COULD BE SUED
IN SMALL CLAIMS COURT BUT THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO LOSE THEIR
HOUSING BECAUSE OF MYSTERY. FOR
THE NEXT FIVE MONTHS THE
TRANSITION TIME PERIOD WHICH
WOULD START TOMORROW. SEPTEMBER
FIRST THROUGH THE END OF
JANUARY NEXT YEAR. IF RUNNERS
COMPETE AT LEAST 25% OF THE
RENT DUE EACH MONTH. DURING THE
TIME UNTIL JUNE OR THE THIRTY
FIRST. THAN ANY REMAINING
MYSTERY FROM THIS TIME PERIOD
WILL BE CONVERTED. TO CONSUMER
DEBT. AND TENANTS WILL BE
PROTECTED FROM EVER BEING
AFFECTED DUE TO THE RESTAURANT.
THIS BILL ALSO PROTECTS
TENANTS. BY EXTENDING THE
NORMAL THREE DAY PAYER QUIT
PERIOD. BEGINS INTERACTION TO
FIFTEEN DAYS GIVING TENANTS
CRUCIAL TIME. TO RESPOND TO
INFECTION NOTICE. IT ALSO
PRESERVES PROTECTIONS CREATED
BY CITIES AND COUNTIES. BY
ENSURING THAT EXISTING
ORDINANCES ARE GRANDFATHERED
IN. AND CAN CONTINUE UNTIL THEY
EXPIRE. ADDITIONALLY ONE STATE
WHAT PROTECTIONS AND ON
FEBRUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. NEW LOCAL MEASURES CAN
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
FINALLY THIS BILL EXTENDS
HOMEOWNER BILL OF RIGHT
PROTECTIONS TO SMALL LANDLORDS
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THEM FROM
FORECLOSURE AND ENSURE THAT
MORTGAGE SERVICERS WORK WITH
BARS ON LOAN MODIFICATION
OPTIONS AT THIS TIME. LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO A WITNESSES.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER CHU I
WILL GO TO OUR FIRST WITNESS.
TO TESTIFY FIVE PHONE THIS IS A
STAKEHOLDER WHO IS- TO HELP
DEVELOP A THIS LEGISLATION
IDEOLOGUE THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
WESTERN CENTER UPON MOTHER. LAW
POVERTY. MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE WITH THIS NUMBER
ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
YOU HEAR ME THIS IS LOTUS
PROCEED. RIGHT THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ON
ALL OR ON BEHALF OF BUT YOUR
PROPERTY CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION- AS MR
CHIU SAID THE BILL BEFORE YOU
PROVIDES IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS
FOR TENANTS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
PAY RENT THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN DURING THE ON GOING
TO THE PANDEMIC. IT NEEDS A
PATH AT THE SAME TIME IT'S NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH THIS IS NOT A
COMPLETE SOLUTION TO THE
LOOMING OF ACTION CRISIS NOR IS
IT A LONG TERM SOLUTION TO THE
VERY REAL FINANCIAL IMPACT THE.
PANDEMIC IS HAVING ON TENANTS.
FOLLOW AND LARGE ANNA FOR
HOUSING. AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THE PRIMARY THAT HELD BACK THE
TIDAL WAVE OF THE SECTION
COMING FROM THE FRONT SHUT DOWN
OVER THE GUARD HOTMEDIA COVE IS
THE PULSE KEEP IT PUT IN PLACE
BY JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ONE. THAT WILL
WILL BE REPEALED TOMORROW
ADDICTION OTHER THAN THOSE FOR
NON PAYMENT WILL BE ABLE TO
MOVE FOR TURNING ON WEDNESDAY
DESPITE THE FACT THAT MUCH OF
THE STATE REMAIN SHUT DOWN AS
WE STRUGGLE TO CONTROL THE
SPREAD OF THE DEADLY DISEASE.
BUT MOST LIKELY THE IMPACT BY
THE THIRD. INCOME BLACK BROWN
RENTERS THE VERY PEOPLE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE COOK A CRISIS EMPIRE STATE
ENTRANCE HOUSING CRISIS. THIS
TOO MUST BE ATTRACTIVE FOR TO
AVOID A CATASTROPHE. IT REMAINS
OUR FIRM POSITION THAT ALLOWING
ANY OTHER ACTIONS TO PROCEED AT
THE TIME OTHER THAN THE
NECESSARY FOR PUBLIC SAFETY OF
THE INTERESTS AND CONTRARY TO
PUBLIC HEALTH. SO WHILE YOU'VE
GOT TO MOVE FORWARD EIGHTY
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH WE
URGE YOU TO DO. WE WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT OUR COLLECTIVE WORK
IS NOT ANYWHERE CLOSE TO DONE
ON THIS ISSUE. THANK. YOU
SACRAMENTO CA NINETY. THANK YOU
AS WELL WILL GO TO. WHEN SAID
CARLTON WITH CALIFORNIA PART.
HE MODERATE PLEASE I KILL WHEN
ATTEMPTING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD EVENING NEVER CARL TO THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND WELL APARTMENT
IS IN OUR NAME 75% OF OUR
MEMBERS ELECTED TEN UNITS AND A
MAJORITY OF THOSE ON SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES AND DUPLEXES.
WHILE YOU'VE ALL HEARD
OPPOSITION ON PREVIOUS COPA
NINETEEN BILLS IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
OUR POSITION THAT SOMETHING HAS
TO BE DONE TO PROVIDE HELP. FOR
TENANTS TRULY AFFECTED BY COVER
NINETEEN AS WELL AS
COMPENSATION FOR LANDLORDS.
SHOULD OF MOM AND POP OWNERS
WHO ARE RISK UPON CLOSURE OR
THOSE WHO DEPEND UPON THE RENT
TO COVER THEIR RETIREMENT. AND
MANY OF THESE OWNERS HAVE NOT
RECEIVED RENT FOR MONTHS. THOSE
OF US WHO CAME TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE INPUT ON AB THIRTY
EIGHT EIGHT AND MET IT'S NOT
THE PERFECT SOLUTION AND
EVERYONE INVOLVED WOULD HAVE
WANTED MORE FOR THEIR MEMBERS
AND THEIR CONSTITUENTS. HOWEVER
DOING NOTHING WAS NOT THE
ANSWER. WE ALL KNOW THAT TO
TRULY ADDRESS THIS CRISIS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO
STEP UP COBIT IMPACTED RENTERS
NEED FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE SO
THEY CAN PAY THEIR RENT. IF IT
CONTINUES TO GO IN PAID WE FEAR.
THAT HOUSING PROVIDERS WILL
EITHER FACE FOR CLOSE. OR IF
THEY CAN'T SELL THEY WILL FAIL
OR CONVERT THEIR PROPERTIES.
THAT MAY MEAN TENANTS LOSE
THEIR HOMES IN THE END. THE
SMALLER PROPERTIES HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND LUDIC LOSING THESE
UNITS ARE WORTH AND
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING SHORTAGE.
AS LAWLER STATED EARLIER IT OUR
WORK IS NOT DONE. AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT IS A TEMPORARY
SOLUTION. AND WE COMMIT TO
CONTINUE OUR WORK TO FIND A
BETTER SOLUTION FOR THOSE
AFFECTED BY COBIT OWNERS AND
TENANTS ALIKE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MISS CARLSON WILL
CONTINUE WITH SUPPORTERS AT
FIRST WITH ANY SUPPORTERS IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WISH TO
SPEAK FASTER SUPPORT FOR THIS
ITEM. C. NINE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY- CALLERS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT. YUP YOU
AREN'T SUPPORTING YOU MY PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF US SIXTY Q. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN REMINDER THIS IS TO
STAGE MANAGER TRANSACTION IN
YOUR POSITION. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KEVIN GOLDY
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. GIVE AN EXTRA
BOTTLE LINE OF FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MAYBE FAN SAYS S.
CI YOU. IN SUPPORT. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ALI FOR MANY WITH
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING AND URBAN RESTRICTED
VISITATION ALSO KNOWN AS BURKE
AND MARK. THANK YOU. NEXT TO A
PHOTO LINEUP SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CAREY MEMBERS
OF THE SOVIET THE ONLY SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANEXO BOTTOM
LINE OF SEVENTY ONE. SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
CURRENT MEMBERS BUT I FEEL LIKE
I FEEL CLAIMS CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIAN IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BUT A LINE OF FIVE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ROB WILSON WITH A CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND THAT HER GOAL
LINE OF SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MISTER CHAIRED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PAT AND GENTLE AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION
WHO HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION ON
AB THIRTY EIGHTY TWO. AFTER
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU AND
AGAIN APPEARED FOR YOU MY PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AND THERE IS NO OTHER
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR I WILL MOVE TO A
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES- FIRST RUN
KINGSTON REPRESENT MULTIPLE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS
MODERATELY PLEASE A COUPON
KINGSTON WITH THIS NUMBER ONE.
HI THIS IS ARUN KINGSTON. WE'RE
PLEASED AFTER. THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION ORANGE COUNTY
PURPOSE OF TEACHING CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN CITIES THE STATE
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION. AND
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ASSOCIATIONS- COLLECTIVELY-
HAVE THE ENTIRE STATE THOSE ARE
THE ONLY TEAM RESTRICTED. PRICE
RESTRICTED. PROF I PERSONALLY
OBSERVED THAT THE WHOLE BIT CAN
GET HORDE. HAS CREATED A GREAT
DEAL HARD H. IT'S CREATED
TREMENDOUS AND DRAIN ON ALL
PARTIES CONCERNED THIS. IS NOT
THE FAULT OF NOT ONLY TENANTS
BUT ALSO NOT PROPERTY OWNERS
AND MANAGERS- WE HURT WE ARE
HURT EVEN DURING MR SHOES- A
NATIONAL BILL- OF A NUMBER OF
SMALL MOM AND POP LANDLORDS.
THAT HAVE NOT RECEIVED RAMPS
CHANGE MARCH IT IS TOTALLY
POSSIBLE WITHOUT LANDLORDS
THOUSANDS OTHERS WON'T RECEIVE
ANY GRANT PAYMENT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH- MARCH OF NEXT YEAR.
ALMOST WELL OVER A YEAR IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT THE- JAIL HAVE-
NOT BEEN EMPLOYED SINCE THAT
TIME AND THAT CREATES A REALLY
DIFFICULT SITUATION. CHAU
SECOND NO ONE CAN DOLLARS YOU
THAT SHOWS NO ONE WALKS ACTIONS.
AND THERE ARE OF LAND THAT HAVE
WORKED HAND IN GLOVE IT SHOULD
BE ARCTIC RELATIONSHIP WITH-
THERE CAN. YOU CRAFT OUT AN
ACCEPTABLE SOLUTION DURING THIS
REALLY DIFFICULT TIME THEY'RE
HAVING SAID THAT. WE WOULD HOPE
THAT THE SUCCESSOR BILL THROUGH
THE- APPROACH HIM REALLY
ESSENTIAL ISSUES THAT I LIKE TO
JUST QUICKLY LAY OUT AND
CONCLUDE BY TESTIMONY FIRST MR
CHIU LEGEND ABOUT- ESTABLISHING
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP.
UNFORTUNATELY WE KNOW OF
IMMEDIATE HARDSHIP OF LANDLORDS.
AT THEY HAVE TO PAY BILLS-
ALDER BILLS. HOWEVER THIS
MEASURE AND I WOULD HOPE THAT.
THAT ADDRESSES THEIR PROVIDES
NO VERIFICATION DURING EACH ONE
OF THE AREAS COVERED AREA. OF
AGUIAR-CURRY BEING MARCH FIRST
TO AUGUST THIRTY FIRST TODAY
THE SECOND ONE- OCTOBER ONE
THROUGH JANUARY. IT IS THEY
DECLARATION OF A FINANCIAL
DISTRESS- THE TECH BUT NO
VERIFICATION AND UNFORTUNATELY
THAT WOULD BE R. S. CENTRAL
ELEMENT THAT I WOULD HOPE THAT
WOULD BE IN- ACTIVE DISCUSSION
AND SOLUTION NEXT TIME. SECOND
THERE WILL BE NO IMMEDIATE
AFFECTION ANYWAY EVEN WHEN
THERE IS- AMERICAN AMERICA. WE
WHY SB THERE WAS BE. WHAT AND
IT WILL COME PRISTINE IS
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE A NUMBER
OF COURTS THAT HELP TO. STARTED
TRACKING THIS MATTER AND THERE
WILL BE UNDER THAT USUAL CASE
THAT WILL BE A GREAT DEAL OF
THAT YEAH. FINALLY WE WOULD
HOPE THAT THIS UP NEXT MARCH
WHAT ESTABLISHED ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP DEFINITION SO YEAH
APPLE DOUBLE ON BOTH NIGHTS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
HARDSHIP- THE TENANT IS ABLE TO
SHELVE THE THIRDS HARDSHIP IT
AND OFFERED TO USE ANOTHER
REFINISHED- WE WANTED EXPRESSED
THESE CONCERNS ARE WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND HOPE THAT WE
ENGAGE IN. ACTIVE DISCUSSIONS
AND GREAT SOLUTIONS- COUNTY
NUMBER WHEN SESSION STARTS UP
ALL OVER AGAIN THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR KINGSTON. MODERATOR WE
HAVE OUR SECOND WITNESS I WANT
TO BE CLEAR THIS- INDIVIDUALS
TESTIFYING AND A NEUTRAL
POSITION- THIS IS- CREAM TO
RECEIVE- IT CALIFORNIA REALTORS
ASSOCIATION A MODERATE. CAN YOU
PLEASE COME UP WITH THIS NUMBER
TO. GOOD EVENING- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- C. A. R. IS NEUTRAL
IN AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT AND
WISHES TO EXTEND OUR SINCERE
THANKS AND GRATITUDE TO THE
CHAIR THE OTHER AUTHORS OF THE
MEASURE. THE ADMINISTRATION.
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TAKING OUR INPUT
CONCERNS SERIOUSLY AND FOR
THEIR VERY HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL UNDER DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES. ANOTHER TO
PREVIOUSLY STATED WORK ON THESE
ISSUES WILL REQUIRE CONTINUED
COLLECTIVE EFFORTS C. R. LOOKS
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO ENGAGE
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS DURING THE INTERIM
AND MEASURES THAT CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES FACING SMALL
HOUSING PROVIDERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU SIR THOSE ARE
WITNESSES- WILL MOVED OUT SAID
BECAUSE OF. INDIVIDUALS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION WILL START. WITH
THE INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEN WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MATER YOU PLEASE- QUEUE
UP ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL. THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT. REMINDER FOR ANY OF YOUR-
REMINDER FOR INDIVIDUALS THIS
IS FOR YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
IN YOUR POSITION. GIVEN
OPPOSITION OF A BILLION I PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF US SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS CHRIS BY
TALKING WITH THE WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION AND
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THE CAN I GET A FEW IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THERE IS NO
ONE HERE. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
MEMBER COMMITTEE WILL TURN TO
COMMITTEE NUMBER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS A MINIMUM OF. THANK
YOU I WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIR-
AND AS A SOMEONE WHO WORKED
REALLY CLOSELY WITH ARCHER
DURING THIS BILL- I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE WORK IN THE
SOCKS IN THE CONVERSATION THE
DIALOGUE THAT WENT INTO THIS- I
THINK THAT- AND HAS HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED BY SOME OF THE
PREVIOUS. WITNESSES IN BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION THIS
BILL DOES NOT SOLVE EVERY
SINGLE. TENANT LANDLORD HOUSING
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE OF
BECAUSE OF IT BUT WHAT IT DOES
DO IS IT PRESENTS THE ONLY
VEHICLE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE. SULFUR
EVERYTHING IT DOES CREATE A
BETTER OPTION THAN NO OPTION
THOSE ARE THE TWO THAT'S THE
DOES OF THE TWO THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS IN FRONT OF US
WE EITHER HAVE NO INACTION
WHICH MEANS MILLIONS OF
INDIVIDUALS- COULD BE LEFT
WITHOUT A HOME- STARTING. IN A
FEW DAYS OR WE VOTE ON A
MEASURE THAT REQUIRES THAT WE
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE BUT IT
DOES HELP A PORTION OF THOSE
MILLIONS OF INDIVIDUALS SO I
WANT I THINK- ALL OF THOSE
INVOLVED I KNOW THAT-
CERTAINLY- WE HEARD THAT
THERE'S MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE- AS WE LOOK AHEAD TO WHAT
COMES AHEAD. AND AS WE TRY TO
PREDICT THE UNKNOWN WE DON'T
KNOW EVERYTHING THAT IS COMING
BEFORE S. AND SO I ABSOLUTELY
EXPECT THAT THIS IS A TEMPORARY
SOLUTION AND THAT WE WILL BE
BACK- WHEN THE LATE WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE RECONVENES TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESSING ASSESS
WHAT'S WORKED WHAT HASN'T. I'M
CERTAINLY I KNOW THAT ON THE
BANKING AND FINANCE SIDE
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT- WE WILL NEED TO DO MORE
FOR PROPERTY OWNERS HOMEOWNERS.
AND LANDLORDS- ON THAT
PARTICULAR SIDE SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED THE
CONVERSATIONS AND THANK ALL OF
THOSE INVOLVED- BUT I DO WANT
TO BE CLEAR THAT THE OPTIONS IN
FRONT OF US ARE EITHER IN
ACTION WHICH MEANS THERE IS.
NOTHING WE WILL DO OR WE WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO VOTE ON
THIS BILL- AS THE ONLY OCT
LEGISLATIVE OPTION AT THE
MOMENT- THAT WILL STILL HELP
SOME EVEN IF IT DOESN'T SOLVE
EVERY SINGLE. CHALLENGE WE HAVE
UPON US TO THINK YOU. ASSEMBLY
IS AMONG. SURE IS EXCELLENT.
AND THERE IS NO MOTIONS ARE
SECOND. TO SET. WE HAVE A
SECOND OR A THIRD OF A MOTION
GABRIEL MEMBERS OF THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT ON THIS
LEGISLATION. IF YOU GET. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN- I STRUGGLE
WITH THIS BILL. BECAUSE YOU
KNOW. FOR ONE SIDE I THINK WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP THAT ARE RENTERS ALL
TENANTS ARE GOING THROUGH- BUT
AT THE SAME TIME I ALSO KNOW A
LOT OF. US PROPERTY OWNERS WHO
MAY JUST HAVE A COUPLE UNITS-
AND THEY STILL HAVE A MORTGAGE
THAT THEY NEED TO CARRY. AND.
SO. I'M NOT SURE WHY WHERE I
WILL BE ON OF THIS BILL I WANT
TO COME TO THE FLOOR BUT IN
COMMITTEE I WILL- OF THING AT
THE SAME TIME I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND THE- THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION'S- FOR.
COMING TO THE TABLE. AND COME
BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH THE- A
SOLUTION THAT THEY THINK. IS
THE MOST RARE THEY THEY CAN
WORK WITH BETWEEN TENANTS AND-
AND LANDLORDS SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU- MR FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SEE IF YOU WERE SOMETHING
THEY DESERVE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WHICH TO MAKE
COMMENTS. I JUST LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO OUR
COMMITTEE CHAIR OF FOR HIS
EXCEPTIONAL KICKS IN. A WORK ON
THIS ITEM I KNOW THAT T WAS A
LOT AS WELL AS THE ANOTHER
MEMBER COMMITTEE AND CHAIR THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
AND IT WAS A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT. I APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING FORWARD SOMETHING
CONSTRUCTIVE. I THINK WE ALL
KNOWLEDGE THAT THIS DOES NOT
SOLVE THE ENTIRETY OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE FACE AS A
STATE. I PERSONALLY THINK I
THINK THIS PILOT IS THE GREEK-
NATIONAL SOLUTION I WOULD BE
FAR PREFERABLE- AND THE
COMPLETE AND TOTAL LACK OF
LEADERSHIP CERTAINLY COMING
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AND OTHER
PLCES IN WASHING DC. ARE WHY
WE HAVE TO TAKE IT UPON
OURSELVES TO FIGURE OUT A
REASONABLE SOLUTION OF WHICH
THIS IS A YOU SEE A DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE HOUSING COMMUNITY
COMING TOGETHER. HOW TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT OR AT LEAST A
PARTICIPATION IN A REASONABLE
SOLUTION- I THINK WE THINK
THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS WOULD HOPE THAT WE
WOULD DO IS TO BRING A
DIFFERENT SIDES TOGETHER. TO
COME UP WITH PRACTICAL
SOLUTIONS PARTICULARLY IN SUCH
A DIFFICULT TIME SO. I TO OUR
CHAIR OF MY HAT IS OFF TO YOU
SIR- WELL AGAIN AND IN PERFECT
SOLUTION IT DOES PROVIDE A
LEVEL OF SUPPORT- THE
CALIFORNIA WON'T HAVE ABSENT
ACTION BY THIS COMMITTEE IN
THIS HOUSE TODAY- AND AGAIN WE
CAN KEEP OUR- HOPE. THAT
THEY'LL BE SOME LEVEL OF TRUE
SOLUTIONS AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
BECAUSE WE KNOW THIS IS NOT A
CALIFORNIA PROBLEM THIS IS A
NATIONAL ISSUE. AND THEREFORE
REQUIRES NATIONAL ACTION BUT
ABSENT THAT- IF THIS THE
NATIONAL GOVERNMENT WILL NOT
LEAD CALIFORNIA WILL- THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE DOING WITH THIS
LEGISLATION MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO. ADVISE. YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOU
CLOSING. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES
REALLY PRE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS AS YOU KNOW THIS WAS
MANY OF RAW THE CLOCK. ON A
FACT MIGHT JOIN AUTHOR THE
CHAIR OF THE SENATE BANKING
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT OUR RESPECTIVE
COMMITTEES DID ARE MANY CO
AUTHORS INCLUDING OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY WHO'S ON
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY- AND JUST
SAY THIS IS A TEMPORARY STOPGAP
MEASURE WE KNOW. WE ARE PUT
INTO PLACE- A SET OF POLICIES
FOR THE NEXT FIVE MONTHS BUT WE
WILL NEED TO MONITOR THE
PANDEMIC THE RECESSION AND
WHETHER THERE'S A CHANGE IN THE
FEDERAL MINISTRATION THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO ENGAGE IN HOPEFULLY
WHAT I THINK OF AS THE LONGER
TERM ULTIMATE SOLUTION TO THIS-
AND THIS BILL IS FAR FROM
PERFECT WE HAVE MORE THINGS
THAT WE CERTAINLY WILL NEED TO
THINK ABOUT BUT AS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA PUT IT- THE CHOICE WE
HAVE IN FRONT OF US IS TO DO
NOTHING OR TO DO SOMETHING. AND
WE CANNOT DO NOTHING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT WOULD BE
CATASTROPHIC SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU SIR- OKAY HELLO
OKAY MCCARTY PROCEED AT THE
MOTION IS TO RECOMMEND THAT THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO BE
CONCURRED IN Q. FIVE Q. I. DEEP
DEEP VOTE GABRIEL. GABRIEL I
GLORIA HI GLORIA I KILEY. KILEY
NOT VOTING ON THE ONE I AM
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I CORPS
OF A QUICK SURVEY. THE BILL IS
OUT. THANK YOU MISTER GORE
WE'RE JUST GONNA DO ADD ONS I
THINK YOU'VE BEEN ON THE ENTIRE
TIME SO WE'LL JUST ADD ON THE
FINAL MEMBERS LET'S JUST GO
THROUGH THE TOP OF THE FILE
FILE ITEM ONE AB SIXTEEN R.
MISTER TANG MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FEET. NO DATE NO. MYANMAR
REMARK I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I. AT SIX EYES CHIU
KNOWS THE BILL'S OUT FILE ITEM
TO AB FOR THIRTY FOUR DALY.
DEEP YES FOUR EIGHT I THE
AMOUNT THE AMOUNT AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I.
THAT'S A UNANIMOUS THE BILLS UP
FILE ITEM THREE AB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE GRAYSON. NEYMAR LIMON NOT
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN IT SAYS MR
GRAYSON- IT'S A. BILL OR
MODIFICATIONS SB THIRTY FIVE.
MAIENSCHEIN HI. EACH WEEK.
SEVEN ICE ONE NOT VOTING THE
BILLS OUT AND- FILING FOR AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA. D. FIVE
DEEP I THE AMOUNT THE AMOUNT I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
DOUBLES UP WE'VE ALREADY DONE
FILE AND FIVE SO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
SERVICE THIS YEAR AND- WE'LL
SEE YOU NEXT YEAR. AT THIS TIME
WE ARE JOB.